today is the first of
august 2021 so it's time for another
monthly update video in which i'm going
to talk about what went on in july
and what we've got coming up in august i
always like to begin
by highlighting three big things so
big thing number one which i'll talk
about in the august portion more
i'm starting a new series of videos
having to do with literature in
speculative fiction
that is in addition to the worlds of
speculative fiction it'll be more like
my
core concept videos shorter videos
focused on
particular works ideas thinkers themes
all those sorts of things big thing
number two you should keep a
lookout in my social media and i'll also
post it here
in the community tab in my channel i'm
going to have some
more classes coming out the people who
want online classes
in the listenable platform and also in
my reason io
academy so keep an eye out for those
and then big thing number three a lot of
behind the scenes stuff going on
my wife andy schacha and i have been
tasked with
organizing the big stoicon this year so
we're doing
a lot of planning the fruits of which
you should see
coming out in august and so you're going
to want to look at the
stoicism today blog housed on the modern
stoicism site
for that but i'll also put things in my
social media about that as well
july was supposed to be a super
productive month
and it was you know pretty productive
but not up to the level that i was
looking at in part because
we've had some illness here in the
household definitely not
covid but other things instead that
sapped a bit of time and strength and
energy
i also had two online classes going
full bore through the month of july and
you know in addition to being online
classes these are six and seven week
variations of what would normally be 15
week classes so
pretty intensive and you know we've
we've been busy with a lot of other
things
as well i had a lot of clients a lot of
meetings this this last month
so video production you know i produced
quite a few things and and we had some
online events
worlds of speculative fiction we brought
the philip jose farmer
world of tears thing to a close
we did a heavy metal class me and scott
taruli that turned out quite well about
best albums by classic bands and what
makes best albums best
i did my usual ama and we had wisdom for
life with my co-host dan i did my
hegel sessions and other sessions for
fans and i went on to
[Music]
you know what would we call them they're
officially podcasts or video channels
but they're really like
forum discussions so president sunday
invited me on for a discussion
about james you know conceptual james
lindsay's
uh takedown of of hegel
and you know diagnosis of hegelianism
being
involved in all these things on the left
and it was you know
his stuff is complete garbage and
[ __ ] but a lot of people
who aren't very intelligent buy into it
and so we didn't get
very far into it before like glaring
errors were coming up and we had a lot
of really great discussion about that
um so that was interesting and then i
went on acid horizon
to talk about nick land's fanged numina
and that was some sort of mixed
reception the people who understand
the material well we're like yeah that's
pretty good you know
the people who are sort of like land
acolytes they hated it
because we were criticizing land but
that was a lot of fun
as well i did some podcast work you know
i
continued um with uh
wd ross and then i started doing these
shorts
as well did quite a few of those did
some episodes on william james
pragmatism
lecture two and some things on chapter
three of pierre adoz philosophy as a way
of life and we finished out the month
starting
some podcast episodes on simon de
bevoir's ethics of ambiguity a very
important work
video work i got three half hour hegel
videos done
not super happy about that but it's
better than zero
i didn't get any book review videos done
but i did get some other things
you know two videos about the city of
milwaukee that that you might like one
was about the
box championship parade here in
milwaukee which was very cool we were
able to like be there
for that um also one of those
you know flowers bees and in this case
there were some other things mixed in
with it
as well um so that that's you know some
some nice stuff and i'll be doing more
of those i did an
unboxing video that was uh kind of kind
of fun to do about
wiley wallaby licorices which i
think are pretty good and you know we
had all the events videos as well
and we did some core concept videos they
were mostly oriented towards what i was
teaching in my classes
so you know stuff on mills on liberty
because we were discussing that work
some videos on judith jarvis thompson's
the trolley problem because we were
discussing that and we finished out
with some videos on richard dawkins and
chapter 11
of his the selfish gene where he's
talking about memes
because we were talking about trolley
problem memes so we had to go
to dawkins for that so that's that's
july
you know the only other thing i can say
about july is
those of you who are worried about sassy
the 18 year old cat she's doing
better she's on various medicines she's
gained a lot of weight back
actually she's getting kind of chunky
again and in good spirits and she's
gotten to go outside a few times which
she really
enjoys as well and i've been getting to
the gym pretty regularly and seeing the
effects and you know taking the long
walks that some
of you see me posting images of in
social media so i'm i'm feeling
pretty good except for the you know the
stomach bug that i had
earlier this this last month so that is
july we have quite a few things coming
up in
august so there's a lot of online events
that you can participate
or enjoy you can watch videos
later of many of these and these are all
in central time so if you are in a
different time zone make sure that you
check the calendar and check the time
before you
miss them right every once in a while i
have somebody who comes in and
they miscalculated and it's at the end
of the event and they're like oh crap i
missed it so don't be that that person
right
on the 7th at noon we will be having
the usual ama that's ask me anything
session streaming you know i'll answer
as many questions as i can get to i
never get to all of them because by the
end of the session
they have piled up quite a bit following
that
on the 7th at 2 p.m for my patreon
supporters
i'll be having a philosophy chat session
on the 11th at 5 p.m we'll have
our public hegel q a and discussion
session that is for anybody who wants to
come
and talk about hegel you don't have to
be a supporter of the half hour hegel
project
in order to do that you just have to
show up for the video conferencing and
we'll talk about
hegel then we have some regulars who
show up we always have some new people
as well on the 14th at
noon and at 1 30 p.m it's a two-part
event we're going to have the worlds of
speculative fiction
session devoted to the
weapon shops of isher novels by a.e van
vogt
one of my favorite classic uh golden age
sci-fi authors a lot of people don't
like him
like damon knight you know famously
bashed him but i actually think he's
pretty good and philip k dick thought he
was awesome as well
so you might want to show up for that
easy enough books to get you can find
them online
and quick read as well as as opposed to
some of the other
sessions stuff that we have talked about
on the 21st
at noon scott truly and i will be
hosting yet another
classic metal class open to anybody
who's got an interest in the music
it's a video conferencing session scott
and i are on
camera nobody else is we're having a lot
of discussion
we engage the audience and we
tackle some sort of interesting issues
in music history music theory philosophy
and their interconnection
on the 26th at 6 00 p.m we'll have our
mke stoic fellowship meeting and we're
going to be looking at cicero's
on duties book two that's that's a sort
of in-depth study
that i'll be there for as a resource and
we'll be
discussing that text and then
on the 29th at noon we'll have the
political theory and practice discussion
i'm yet to deciding what i want to talk
about in that session that's a live
streaming one as well
then i also want to point out every week
on saturdays at 4 pm central time you
can listen
live on the internet to wisdom for life
our radio show that i host with dan
hayes
where we apply philosophy to everyday
life and
this month on thursdays at noon
central time i will be doing live
readings from my book reason fulfilled
by
revelation so if you want to hear the me
the author
reading from my book and then stick
around for a q a and discussion that
will be
every thursday this month and uh yeah
that's
that's pretty much about it as far as
events go so it's
pretty packed right i'm going to be
doing a lot more writing
in medium as i mentioned i'm bringing
classes
out in two different platforms
listenable and my reason i owe academy
i'm also going to be doing some more
podcast stuff we've got you know more
shorts coming up but also more stuff on
simonda bouvoir's
ethics of ambiguity the book where she
managed to do what her
partner sartre could not do in all of
being and nothingness
i'll also have some podcast episodes
coming out this month
on aleister mcintyre's after virtue
particularly one of the later chapters
discussing the notion of a practice
and i'll have some podcast episodes on
my colleague john sellers and his really
excellent
article on philosophy as a way of life
video stuff i'm going to tell you about
the new stuff in
at the very end but let me just run down
the list of what i'm going to be
trying to get done this this month so
core concept videos i've i've had some
foucault thumbnails waiting for me to
get them done for
a long time and i'm going to buckle down
and get on to
that particular article which you'll see
coming out
and then some some schopenhauer stuff as
well people have been asking for that
for a very long time
just so happens that coincides nicely
with
what i i've got coming up in the classes
i'm preparing for my ethics classes
this fall i'll be doing you know my half
hour hegel
as well we'll try to see if we can get
it back up to six videos a month or not
i'm going to do at least one more quick
take advice video for for viewers
um i'll most likely be doing some
personal videos
uh particularly given that it's my
birthday this month it's also the
anniversary of my dad's death so i'll be
doing a bit of thinking about that sort
of stuff
probably do some sadler's stories and
i've got a lot of book reviews that i
need to get to
but before i get to to
the very end let me tell you about the
other kind of videos i'm going to be
doing
so i am teaching a new kind of class for
me
this semester at milwaukee institute of
art and design
it is a 15-week class that is focused on
ursula k le guin's books of earthsea
which are you know there's six
volumes but they're all available in one
giant
omnibus volume along with some of the
earlier stories that set the scene
like the rule of names for example and
we are going to be spending the entire
15 weeks
looking at these wonderful novels and
short stories
from philosophical literary
anthropological
political you know all sorts of
perspectives and
including illustration so i
am going to be shooting an entire new
sequence of videos
on ursula kayla green's earth sea stuff
also on a few other things like her from
elf land to poughkeepsie essay which is
about you know what what um
fantasy fiction is is about and uh you
know
it's it's metaphysics you could say and
i thought well this is a great
opportunity for me to do something i've
wanted to do for
a while so i'm going to be shooting some
new videos and they're going to be
shorter they're going to be focused not
just on philosophy
but on all these other things having to
do with speculative fiction and i'm
going to begin with ursula k le guin
with two of her stories but i'm also
going to begin
with something else that i i read as i
was preparing for the philip jose farmer
and i want to follow up on which is
his story the lovers so that will be
coming out
this month as well new videos new kinds
of videos and hopefully
people will will enjoy them and and get
something out of them so
a lot of stuff coming up in
this month of august my two of my
classes
ethics for artisan designers and ursula
k le greens earth c
philosophy and literature are starting
towards the end of the month and i'm
also gearing up for the third class that
i'm teaching for carthage college a
business ethics class
which will begin in september so there
we go
i hope you can make it to some of these
online events and i hope you have a
great month ahead
you